bonjour tout le monde eh bien on va
continuer notre série sur sûrs et
liquides
on va regarder un peu des parties sur la
défense française donc trois parties
dans les trois prochaines vidéos et donc
celle là c'est une partie qui a joué bas
à mannheim mannheim j'y reviendrai donc
quand on parle un peu plus de son
histoire donc en 1914 et il a les blancs
on ramasse à pelle fahrni hand fahrni
non je pense à jean rangs allemands et
est donc française et il joue son coup
j'ai cinq est ok donc dessus plusieurs
opportunités pour les noirs mais fausse
at c'est le coup classique qui est elle
dans cette partie donc d autres options
c'est fou b4 on verra une partie de sulo
valeur les ventes de mac chan ou bien
sûr l'option de toujours échangé avec 4
encore maintenant très possible il faut
s'attacher été joués et donc dans cette
partie allait qui n'a joué le coup h 4
est en fait c'est le nom d'une variante
qui porte encore son nom maintenant on
appelle ça la tacc chatard et liquides
parce que donc j'adore ce devait être un
joueur français je pense mais qui a dû
plus ou moins mettre ça à la mode et à
l'équipe en fait c'était le premier
joueur à haut niveau à jouer et donc
faire gagner ses lettres de noblesse à
cette variante langage 4 c'est quoi le
truc c'est ben moi après calais 17 le
fou g5y attaquer donc les blancs le
choix de l'échangé de me prend et
continue part en part par f4 donc c'est
la ligne classique en général donc les
normes oms et de faire du contrôle
d'accès 5 alors pas tout de suite tout
de suite parce qu'il y aura toujours des
problèmes et qui avait cinq attention
pourquoi bassam est une fourchette ans
et 7 et sa menace aussi de faire échec
en d6 donc si on fait rock qui est sesat
les balles et blanc ont regagné minimum
une qualité alors c'est même quand même
possible de jeu comme ça notons en
partie rapide ou blitz parce que les
normes aussi de vite ouvrir le centre et
faire des petites menaces
après c'est quand même assez douteux
donc vaut mieux pas donc beauté noire
dans ce genre de position ne pas faire
ces cinq direct mais d'abord rock rock
d'abord pour faire ses 58 ou à six
essais 5 ensuite quand même voilà ça
reste toute façon l'idée principale des
marges avec ses 5 dans ce genre de
position voilà à noter tient juste que
sur roc cavaliers trois blessures là les
normes de jouer ces cinq six ou sept
fois qu'ils aient b5
en fait il ya plus qu'une menace
cecchini 6,7 et donc si on fait qu'elle
lycées 6 onces unccas de fuite pour la
tour donc et c'est cette simple coup
d'épée dans l'eau et sur un goût comme
kylie 6 en fait rien de grave parce que
les noirs peuvent échanger ici disons
cavalli prend et ce maître aminé ce
cavalier en faisant et fils pour
attaquer le centre est en fait là les
blancs seraient déjà très mal voilà donc
un camion des six c'est pas toujours
fantastique surtout sonores peuvent
contre-attaqué comme ça juste dans
l'autre cas de figure avant comme je
vous disais après f4 c5 trop vite qui
avait cinq là le problème c'est qu'il ya
échec
donc ça va à la fois des rockets les
noirs est bon la dre du coup c'est très
pénible
voilà voilà donc pourquoi cette possible
mais ça joue mais hk donc c'est l'autre
option et c'est un grand bidon qui vise
à favoriser le développement rapidement
et avoir du jeu le long de la colonne h
alors les noirs peuvent évidemment
refusé de granby je pense qu'une bonne
manière juste recueilli ces six c'est le
coup que je propose de jouer pour les
noirs dans mon dvd sur la française que
bah vous pouvez renseigner pour le
trouver un toute façon j'en avais parlé
sur bitstream
voilà mais fou prend g5 sa bombe associe
une option tout à fait viable
puis on prend 2 me prend hélas des qui
n'a joué cavalier h3 donc développe le
cavalier gagne un temps sur la dame est
en fait l'idée cela remet vers 4 h 5
éventuellement tapé là bas au lieu de
callas 3 il ya dam des trois qui a un
coût plus moderne et qui est pas mal en
fait il est deux parties au début des
années 2000 qui met bien attirer l'oeil
c'était une partie de gris chucky avec
les blancs contre bruyneel donc grand
maître suédois en 2002 aient une partie
aussi de kasparov contre cauchemar en
rapide par contre pas joué de vie de fer
corse n'y avait joué cavalier c6 ici
cavaliers de 3,2 kasparov attaque
attaque la dame oui bah ce qu'elle sait
si c'est quoi il est excellent et blanc
vont prendre un set
les noirs peuvent reprendre et du coup
plus personne ne défende et 4 donc oui
ça serait très bien paru noire mais
masquée sport a fait d'abord qualif 3
la dame doit doit partir donc plutôt
verges et six pour pas perdre un set
sinon sur dame sait tous qu'on attend
pour un chat
il ya eu échange est là le problème pour
les noirs ce qu'écrit b5
donc on crée une menace là dessus et si
les noirs défendent avec trois des huit
et ben à ce moment là il ya l'autre qui
valait carrément g5 menace à la fois
qu'il y ait cet écueil point de six dont
trois des huit pas possible mais du coup
après roy c7
je vais parcours jeu maintenant la
partie kasparov a repris ans s est donc
déjà il ya plus de viande - est juste
une très bonne position
parce que meilleure structure pions des
pièces plus active etc etc
donc c'était panne et c'est fantastique
le coup de torchon cas ici si si si mais
une autre partie donc celle de great
food dont je parlais qui était pas mal
c'était g6 et ben ok qu'il y avait trois
pour se développer qu'en revanche la
dame grand roque
alors il ya six jouets bon pour vider un
peu peut-être les calibrer 5 et
compagnie dame e3 on se dirige vers les
cases noires affaiblie ces cinq prises
dame prend bombe menés sur les blancs
veulent pas veulent pas être changé
d'âme en nature de moins au jeu pourront
pour l'initiative surtout là avec la
montage de développement d'un f4
tri66 fou des trois c'est bien pour
développer la nb4 et là un coup
fantastique mais qui est fait est qu il
est parti je montrerai ensuite faux et 4
pourquoi fantastique c'est donc à deux
reprises moi c'est la partie c'est le
cavalier qui va venir ici et on va
appuyer sur les casses faibles notamment
moqué ici ce qui va arriver et en fait
si les noirs ne font rien méprise le fou
il y aura éventuellement des sacrifices
sur des 5 et autre chose c'est qu'ils g5
peut arriver pour attaquer f7 et donc le
fougueux 4 sert aussi à bloquer la dame
pour pas qu'elle échange de dame voilée
coups fantastiques et non dans la partie
et puis on prend qu'elle valait prend
touré fuite bon bah il défend un peu un
peu f7 ils auraient pu éventuellement
jouer dams est dès maintenant mais ça
n'a pas empêché les problèmes à base de
kenny 6 éventuellement ou 2 kg 5
avec qui des six ans suit et on prend
accepte donc beaucoup de soucis pour les
noirs touré fuite à trois lames et
partida me trois jeux à vitesse rapide
vous pourrez l'analyse est de votre côté
si vous voulez où la trouver dans la
base donc c'est que j'ai tout comme
greenhalgh mais en gros on va le prendre
et noir quoi ces îles ont une pièce de
plus mais rien ne vaut de leur position
les cases noires sont complètement
trouvé et il va vraiment très vite dans
cette position-là donc ce coup dam des
trois c'est un coup à prendre très au
sérieux en fait un bref bon on en était
bien loin c'était début des années 1900
à 1914 et donc dans la partie s'est
passé comme ça mais c'est assez logique
au vu de la part des blancs juste les
noms ont joué un mauvais coup qu'avec
les fuites très passif et en plus tout
de suite allé keane va pointer du doigt
le problème
le défaut de ce coup
je dois dire que en fait sûrement
camions de neige pour le rck ici 6 en
fait c'est un coup de dé veloppement
disons est applicable jusqu'à valley
peut-être à sortir le fond en 17 ou quoi
ou l'homme qui avait 17 ans verra son
verbe et 6 ou etc mais surtout après
dame g4 on veut faire j'ai 6 puis h5 et
ont créé une structure de pion à ses
solides et on évite de se faire se faire
défoncer comme entraîneur on va voir ce
qui se passe dans la partie après
quelques fuites
alors juste ce que je veux dire oui le
fou au 4° chucky ça vient pas de nulle
part
et donc c'est l'intérêt trie les partis
classiques donc la vente des parties des
liquides ont bien sûr il y avait pas que
lui juste une tirer sur les joueurs
français mais en fait là à voir une
partie entre bogoliubov et spillmann en
oui c'est passer ça bon je vais un peu
vite pour pour passer les coûts mais
faisait 3 dans les fuites
hélas le coup je pars bogoliubov bam
flou 4 fantastiques
donc en fait il veut juste claqué sur
des 5 et ouvrir la position est que le
roi en 8
ben et que sa faiblesse soit plus
flagrante courage et envie de dire c'est
toutefois un principe
bon je vous le dis souvent mais tu as on
voulait déjà dû de partout quand
l'adversaire en manque de développement
ou à leroy faible ou exposées il faut
ouvrir les lignes pour pour l'attaqué
est donc dans la partie une fuite comme
ça est bon les blancs l'avait emporté de
fort belle manière en fait qu'il y ait
six échecs presse prises vont dans les
fuites fc sète alors on attaque à la
fois le cavalier et on menace de venir
en 18 matches caillé 17
alors s'ils jouent et qui a aidé 5 on
pouvait simplement prendre
et puis je te rendre ensuite pour mater
est surpris on prend tout reprend ses
matchs donc calais 17 avaient été jouées
boom caïds et 5 très bien joué il se
démène comme i peu là un coup que j'aime
bien
robin et c'est très bien je me sens fait
pourquoi il veut faire quoi avec les
blancs il veut il veut prendre en d5
c'est son idée mais là ça serait juste
super mauvais parce que les noirs il
ferait d'un mach 6 échecs on évite les
chèques je pense je le roy on ramène une
tour et ils font rock au suivant et le
roi est caché et zone caisse de plus du
coup le petit coup droit bien c'est
prophylactique ceux à éviter tout
dommage 6 20h06 la dame orages 6 il ya
maintenant 17 ans plus personne ne
défend ici donc les dents en fait au
cours et ont paralysé et ils ont fait
autour des 8 suprise crise prises et bat
le problème c'est que sa menace
c'est un acheteur des huit matches et
surtout prend des cinq dames ses huit
matches donc très belle partie des
attaques de bombay ou boeuf mais c'est
encore ce soir tu fous quatre ans je
vous remonterez une fois de plus
l'idée donc degrés tout car employé
quasiment 100 ans plus tard quoi alarmer
nombre est passé des liquides et son
adversaire jacques cavallier fuite donc
il n'est pas terrible
maintenant reste à voir pourquoi on peut
mettre sur pause et chercher et le coup
joué en fait et à vrai dire très logique
c'est dame g4 alors pourquoi pas ce
qu'on attaque g7 et on menace aussi de
prendre des cinq puisque le pion aux six
écuries
parce qu'il prend il le faut c'est vite
en l'air donc d'alger cap très simple et
efficace a donc attaque j'ai cette
attaque des 5 et prépare actuellement
grand roque bon les noms ils trouvent un
moyen de défendre quand même il fallait
25 et surprise en passant puis on prend
bien sûr on peut pas prendre un des 5
parce que plus on prend échec sa
différence on a pu lire ici
donc allons perdre est parti mais bien
sûr bon allez qui n'a d'abord rauque et
donc ils réitèrent la menace de kelly
prend des 5 et noir essayer de renforcer
tout re 1 donc là et bien évidemment
créé le vis-à-vis et on veut sacrifier
en d5
par exemple dans des lustres hâtive
s'énerve on fout 17 pour développer un
peu on peut y aller à fond prises prise
prise ils ont créé leur fasse d'amd 8
pour garder son pion protéger et bahia
simplement d'amener cette menace qui
avait prôné 6 menace de me prend tout
mon nas tout est fini donc surtout re 1
les noirs ont fait roi des 8 bon ok il
se démène comme ils peuvent mais bon
c'est vrai que pour juste avoir un pion
de plus d'un lourd lourd tribut que ce
qui ce qu'ils subissent dans cette
partie tu auras justice très bien joué
donc actives la tour on peut doubler
éventuellement pour taper sur h cette
visée f6 et ses terrains c'est très bien
il ya eu 5 ok donc attaque la dame
bon bah il l'enlève il n'y a pas de
prise un de cavaliers parce qu'il ya le
clouage long de la colonne avec la dame
la dame rose 7 km et 17 fou d3o que
bondues petits coups vont ils tentent de
colmater comme il peut avec le 4 et
d'hommes g3 donc dame g3
bah ça peut en tout leur permettre
d'aller par la dalle et par là bas aussi
donc pas mal joué dans les stades a été
joué hélas le moment de sacrifices
arrive et donc c'est un peu comme dans
pas mal de positions qu'on a vu ok on a
une pièce de moins avec les blancs mais
en fait toutes les pièces blanches ou
contrats en pièce noire
ils ont le roi faible regardez les tours
comme elles sont dans un état
catastrophique le fougueux bouge pas et
c est ça va arriver de tous les côtés
rioux tour g8 clignotants sur la dame
damas 3 donc du coup la dame peut être
venir par ici et aussi l'autre menace
c'est de faire payer des six parce qu on
attaque la dame on pourra jouer avec du
tour 8 ensuite et c'est avec ces dames
g7 a été jouée alors un petit truc
illustratif si les noirs zeddam 7,3
changer les dames
bon bah c'est bien de refuser l'échangé
toujours pareil quand le roi de verser
est faible en c3 pas mal vu qu'on défend
la tour donc on pourra faire des
découvertes avec son cavalier
disons un coup comme ça pour montrer on
peut simplement échanger voiliers et qui
allie ses cinq attaques la dame donc
avec la tour dames bouge échecs et
maintenant le roi doit revenir sur la
colonne eux ont refait nouvelles
découvertes et on va gagner une qualité
voilà bon ça c'était juste une petite
vente comme ça rien n'a été forcée juste
pour montrer le potentiel de la position
blanche
bon tout cas les canaris la fedom g7
cahier 10,6 kébé 6 et lincou marrant pas
mal payé 8 c'est rare qu'on voit un coup
comme ça de cahiers qui va sur
l'échiquier branger surtout si tôt dans
la partie on va dire donc le même
l'attaqué il est venu en chef cette ci
venant 17 mai à se planquer problème 6
fourchette donc vient f7 et il a en fait
via un math à suivre
c'est dam des six échecs alors pourquoi
maths à suivre parce que si dame 17 ont
fait de me prendre 6 du coup le roi n'a
pas de casse de fuite ses intérieurs ce
qu'avait dit si qui prend la casse c7
est donc d'amener cette dame prend dame
fini et sur food et cette quête il coup
joué dans la partie enfin non il va déjà
demander s'ils refusent et 17 ont fait
danser satc mat
voilà donc battre bonne partie d'
attaque assez facile il était bien aidé
par le coup cavaliers fuite très tôt
dans l'ouverture
donc après 4,4 ici ça c'est mauvais mais
il a mais il ya très bien attaqué en
tout cas ça a été de pièces tout ça est
quoi qu'il en soit c'est que ce coup h 4
donc dans l'ouverture reste encore à
l'actuel à des coûts principaux dans
cette variante est toujours considéré
comme dangereux il faut bien connaître
avec les noirs pour pour survivre donc
donc voilà c'était juste une petite
partie un peu théorique d'aller keynes
la française
on sent regardera d'autres ensuite allez
à bientôt